fear is now spreading even faster than
the coronavirus the face masks on the
streets of Europe and the plunging stock
markets around the world are evidence
that there's widespread public belief
that kovat 19 is a real and growing
threat don't panic urge the Prime
Minister it's absolutely vital that
people do feel reassured the NHS is a
fantastic service we've made every
possible preparation thought any any
eventualities but the government is now
looking at wider action to slow down the
virus if it begins to spread in the UK
crowds an obvious risk from sporting
fixtures to schools the chief medical
officer said tough decisions will need
to be made with potential impact on
everyday life everybody knows that the
kinds of things you consider are
reducing mass gatherings school closures
which may or may not be appropriate for
this particular virus we don't know yet
we need to find that out but we have to
look at all of them and say how likely
are they to work and what's our evidence
base here what's the social cost of this
because one of the things is really
clear with this virus much more so than
flu is anything we do we're gonna have
to do for quite a long period of time
probably more than two months and the
implications of that on nontrivial the
virus is spreading rapidly in some parts
of the world most alarmingly in Iran
where hazmat teams are now disinfecting
buses in an attempt to get on top of an
epidemic thought to be far worse than
official statistics suggests even the
vice president now has it the head of
the World Health Organization called
this is not a time for fear this is a
time for taking action now to prevent
infections and save lives
people could be worried and rightly so
but the most important thing is to calm
down and do the right things to fight
this very dangerous virus the w-h-o says
the world is at a decisive point if
countries fail to contain the virus it
will spray
rapidly Thomas more Sky News